Okay welcome back to Gary's Economics
today we are
gonna explain
one of the biggest and most misunderstood
economic questions of our time.
Why is housing so expensive?
Okay so
this is obviously
pretty much the biggest economic question
everybody wants to know. You might be asking
why we've not covered it on the channel before
and the answer is that we did cover it.
Because it was obviously such a big issue
this was one of the first videos we ever shot
on this channel maybe four or five years ago.
If you wanna see me back when I used to shoot my videos
walking around East London
looking younger and fresher
we'll put the old one in the description
but it only got about 5,000 views
cause nobody knew who I was at the time
So now we are gonna explain why housing is so expensive
and when I realized nobody had seen that old video
I was quite excited to do one
because I think we can really learn a lot
about some of the really
common ways in which the way that we talk about
and think about economics is
is kind of dumb and is kind of wrong
and also I just think that this really
really important question is really
really commonly misunderstood basically
so I wanna explain in some quite simple ways, why the
the way that you think about housing
and the way that you think about the expensiveness
of housing is wrong.
So the first thing you need to understand
about the expensiveness of housing
is that it is a global issue
and what you often see
with housing and the expensiveness of housing
is that people seem to think
that it is something that is happening
specifically in their city and
when you, as I have done
you study and work with people from all over the world
and you travel around and when I travel around
I always like to speak to people about the economy.
Basically everyone
in pretty much every big city in the world
thinks that there is a massive housing
affordability problem specifically in their city
so this is true in London and in New York
and in Los Angeles and in Tokyo
and in Shanghai and in Rio de Janeiro
and in Mumbai
and in Melbourne and Sydney and Vancouver and Toronto
I could just keep listing cities and cities
and I was in Portugal
in Lisbon and Porto, I was in Milan
basically everywhere you go
people think that there is a housing crisis in just
their city
and I think that is the first thing
that can teach us something
which is that this is quite obviously,
once you step back and
get a bit of distance and look at it
this is quite obviously a global problem
which must therefore have a
a global cause so for all
the guys out there who think this is specifically
Sadiq Khan's fault, for those of you who don't know
Sadiq Khan is the mayor of London,
I hate to break it to you
but this is happening everywhere
and if it's Sadiq Khan's fault
he must be a really powerful guy
because this is happening
in every city across the world
and there is a real tendency
for people to think that the low affordability
of housing in the city or the region that they live
is being caused by their local mayor,
is being caused by their local planning policy.
That basically can't be true. If that was true
it wouldn't be happening in like
pretty much every major city in the world
so that's your first clue that this is misunderstood
it's global it's everywhere.
So it doesn't make any logical sense
to look specifically for the cause of the problem
to something that's happening specifically in
your town or your city
because it's not happening just there.
So then next we can take a step back further
and I think this is probably the most
interesting point I'm gonna make in the whole video
so if you only take one thing away
listen to this.
So I'll explain to you
that the problem is not just in your city
the next thing that I'm gonna explain
and I think
this really helps us to understand
what is going on here
is it's not happening just in houses
maybe that isn't immediately clear what I mean
so at at the beginning of Covid
and I've spoken about this a few times on the channel
I realized
very quickly
that the rich would acculate a lot of money
and I knew for like relatively obvious reasons
that that was gonna push asset prices up
because rich people
when given money
tend to spend almost all of it on assets
so I went and put a massive bet on
on the gold price going up
and since the beginning of the gold price
I put that on something like 1400 dollars
1450 or something like that
and now I don't even know
I think it's 2,500
I think it's it could be way more than that
I think it's
let me check actually we can cut it in because
I think it's something crazy now, 3,400 yeah
so I put that on at 1450
something like that and now it's more than $3,300
so just just since the beginning of Covid, 2020
you've seen in five years
the gold price go up about two and a half times
so massive massive increase in gold price
but it's not just gold right
like at the moment basically
every stock market in the entire world
is at an all time high
if you look at the US stock market massive
massive all time high
if you look at the German stock market
but also the gold price land prices
you look at the price of of farmland
it's gone through the roof
if you look at the price of even things like luxury art
luxury cars like basically every asset in the world
obviously with some exceptions
but every sort of hard
long term asset has massively increased in price
not just in the last five years since Covid
but the last 15 years since
since the Great Recession
the last 30 years
so when you step back and you get a bit of distance
what you see is what has happened to
to house prices and in housing
is not at all unique to house prices and to housing
like
just like it's not unique to your city
it's happening everywhere
it's not unique to housing
it's happening in basically every asset
what you have seen in the short term
the medium term and the long term now
is just a massive increase in the price of basically
all assets when compared to things like wages
and I think this is the main way that its misunderstood
right because the housing crisis
for very obvious understandable reasons
the crisis of housing affordability
is always thought about as a crisis of housing
and then the the solutions and
and the
the causes and the reasons are always spoken about
as if they are specific to the housing market
people always love to talk about
they're not building enough houses
people like to say it's because of immigration
but if it's because of us not building enough houses
why is the gold price trebled
why why are the stock prices trebling
why are land prices you know
quadrupling
This is a global asset price crisis
it doesn't make any sense
if you walk into the supermarket
and the price of everything has trebled
and then you pick up the coffee and you say
why is coffee trebled and I say to you
that's because something crazy
happened in the coffee market
and this by the way
is exactly what happened during Covid
so at the beginning of Covid
it was very clear
there was gonna be a big increase in inequality
a big cash accumulation by the rich
and I was able to predict, if you don't believe me
go and watch the first video on the channel.
I was able to predict as early as March 2020
that there would be a massive inflation crisis
and that prices of everything would go up
and yet when the inflation crisis actually happened
people had a real tendency to be like
well the coffee price has gone up
because something weird has happened to coffee
and the price of a sugar has gone up
because something weird has happened to sugar and
and the rents have gone up
because something weird has happened to the rent market
and holidays have got more expensive
because something
weird has happened in the holiday market
and I think this is a really classic example of a very
very common way in which economists
and journalists who talk about economics
understand poorly and explain poorly the economy
which is they love to look at
kind of small picture explanations
for example if something's happened to house prices
it must come from the housing market
and they're very generally unable to see like
big picture causes
because it's not that hard to recognize well
house prices have gone up
but so have all other assets
so really what's actually happened is
is an asset price crisis
but economists just just never look at this basically
and you end up with
with these basically wrong explanations
which which is the
the problem is we're not building enough houses
the problem is
the problem is immigrants
the housing crisis is not a housing crisis
the housing crisis is a crisis of asset affordability
all asset prices have gone up enormously
and that means you can't afford them
and now we're gonna explain why.
So to explain why it is very
very simple really
I can do it in one sentence.
When you give rich people money
they buy assets okay I'm not Jeff Bezos
I'm not a billionaire, I'm like a
I suppose you could say like moderately rich person
if you were to give me a hundred grand
I could tell you exactly I would go that day
and buy 100 grand of assets
that is what I would do
because I have enough money to live my life
I don't need any more money
I don't need to spend any more money
because I'm relatively rich
I have everything that I need
if you give me 100 grand
I will buy 100 grand of assets
and that is true for the vast majority of rich people
if you give rich people a ton of money
they buy assets, that's where it goes
so when we saw at the beginning of Covid
what should have been relatively clear,
it is still not often spoken about.
When we saw that rich people were gonna accumulate
trillions of dollars, pounds
euros, it should have immediately been extremely obvious
that house prices would go up
like nothing could be more obvious right
If we give £1 trillion
to the richest people in the country
obviously of course
house prices and stock prices
and the gold price will go up
this is nothing, nothing could be more obvious
and for the basic simple reason
you are competing with billionaires
and multimillionaires for ownership of the assets
so if these guys start to accumulate
enormous amounts of money
the asset prices will go up and
you will get less and they will get more
and this is what is happening in housing
this is what is happening in housing
the rich accumulated a ton of money during Covid
but that is just
a continuation of a pre existing trend
which was the rich are getting richer and richer
and richer and richer
as they accumulate larger and larger and larger
ownership of wealth that generates for them
more and more and more passive income
and there's basically
nothing they can do with that passive income
other than to buy the rest of the wealth
and that is why you're seeing house prices going up
that is why you're seeing stock prices going up
that is why you're seeing land prices going up
that is why you're basically
seeing all prices going up
these guys have tons of money
that they need to do something with
and they're using that to buy assets
and that is really why housing is expensive
but one thing
I think that kind of obscures this a little bit
is if we were to talk about gold or housing
it will kind of be obviously true
if you give rich people a ton of money
they're gonna go and buy gold
they're gonna go and buy,
if you talk about gold or stock market
it's gonna be obviously true
they're gonna buy gold and stocks
but when you look at housing
housing is actually quite a special asset
in the context of western economies
especially here in the UK
especially in in the US for example
Housing is the asset
which is most likely to be owned by ordinary people
so most people don't have enormous
stock market portfolios
but a lot of ordinary people still in this country
in the US
in a lot of western countries own their own house
which may
in many cases nowadays be worth half million pounds
£1 million
So that what you have here
is the fact that there seems to be a kind of conflict
right because
even though we know
rich people buy tons and tons of stocks
rich people don't appear to directly buy
tons and tons of housing
and what you're seeing here is basically,
I did a video on on mortgages
earlier this year
and I really wanted to do that video because basically
mortgages are the way in which rich people
buy and own your house, so
I've got a whole video on that
so if you want to go and watch the mortgage video now
after you can watch that
but mortgages is a balanced system
the amount of money lent in society
equals the amount of money borrowed
so we've clearly seen
that the average size of a mortgage has massively
massively increased which means your average person
your average family here in the UK
in the US
across the world has this massive mortgage debt
something people don't realize is
if one group of society has a massive debt
then somebody else has to accumulate a ton of money
this is the way that debt works
you cannot be in debt to nobody
so it is only possible
for ordinary people to suddenly have these massive
massive massive mortgages
if there is a group in society
that is suddenly
accumulating this massive amount of money
this massive amount of credit
probably the easiest way I think to visualize that is,
say I'm a rich person
I've got a million pound cash spare
I can do two things with that
I can either go and buy the house
or I can lend it to my sister who buys the house
the end result on the price of houses
is exactly the same so
rich people are pushing up the price of all assets
including housing
but when they push up the price of housing
it often comes through this channel of mortgage lending
and the reason you are seeing mortgages get much
much much bigger
is because rich people are pushing up the house prices
but they are also
simultaneously offering large amounts of
of mortgage lending
so it gets a bit obscured by mortgages
but the
simple truth of the matter
is really simple right
you know if you are Rishi Sunak
if you are Jeff Bezos, Elon Musk
Donald Trump, you know
you can only live in five or six
or seven or eight houses but you can own
especially by the channel
of mortgage lending and owning credit
you can own 1,000 houses you can own 10,000 houses
and it's the same with the government you know
they're lending money to the government
that's the way they're taking possession essentially
of government assets
they're lending money to mortgage borrowers
that's the way they're taking possession of
housing assets
and in things like stocks and shares and land and gold
they directly buy these things. If you look
this is another point I wanna make
people often
look at the current level of unaffordability
of housing and they look at graphs
such as house price versus average wage
and they see that in the last 10
20 30 years
the average house price in the UK for example
has become extremely expensive relative to wages
compared to what it was 30 40
50 60 years ago and they often then say
oh well
that means housing now is unsustainably expensive
it is unaffordable for ordinary people
and house prices will have to come down.
Go and look at what housing affordability is like
in the west in London
in New York
compared to extremely unequal places in the world
like Mumbai, like Shanghai
like Hong Kong
like Rio de Janeiro like Sao Paolo
or compared to what housing affordability was like
here in the UK 100 or 200 years ago
when things were unequal, what you will find is
the historic outlier is actually not now
when housing is very unaffordable.
The historic
outlier is that period after the Second World War
when housing was affordable.
If you read about the history of of the UK or Europe
you know if you read your Dickens
and you will see that for most of history
housing was not affordable
and that was because for most of history
we had very high levels of inequality
we had this dipping inequality in the post war period
and what that literally means
is that dipping wealth
inequality means assets being owned by ordinary people
now we've moved towards a much more unequal society
the rich are much richer
ordinary people are much poorer
what that means is
you are increasingly competing with billionaires
and multi millionaires
with enormous amounts of passive income
for ownership of the houses
and you can't compete with them,
and housing
will continue to get more and more unaffordable
as long as inequality increases
which its doing and which will continue to do
so the reason house prices are expensive
is because the rich are really
really really really
really rich now and
you can't compete with them
and unless you do something about that
you won't be able to.
So this is the untold story of housing
the untold story of affordability of housing
which is the real truth
is what you're simply seeing is
a change in distribution
a change in equality, a change in relative power
You're losing, they're winning.
So what does that mean about the kind of commonly given
stories about housing.
The biggest one in this country is definitely
just build more just build more just build more
this idea that housing is expensive
you should just build more houses
so let's discuss that.
So before we shot this video
I just quickly went out onto my balcony over there
and I did a little count
of how many cranes I could see
I counted 13 cranes out there
just what I can see from from my balcony
so we are building more you know
we are building more
and if you go out to Ilford where I grew up
which is
a very poor, central Ilford is a very very poor low wage
low rent
area of  outer east London
they are just building and building and building
there's like a 40 floor skyscraper of flats in
in one of the poorest parts of London
and they're just everywhere, we are building them
we are building them but
if you exist in a world
where all asset prices are increasing aggressively
quickly and that is what is driving house prices
how many houses do you think you need to build
here in London to stop or reverse a global
massive increase in the cost of all assets
you know it's not possible
you know if your town is being flooded
you are not gonna save your house
by just bailing your bucket out
you need to deal with
the massive increase here
and I think what you are seeing
and I see this all the time in economics and politics
is this aggressive focus on small scale issues
with this increasingly absurd
refusal to deal with what is driving it
inequality is increasing
inequality is increasing rapidly
what that means is you get less
they get more and
it means your house will be unaffordable
you're not gonna deal with that
by building more houses
you need to deal with that by stopping inequality
growth okay
but what if you do build more
because we are building more
we will build more.
I wanna talk a little bit
and I have mentioned it before on the channel
about what inequality does to the physical
shape of cities and to the physical shape of countries
When you live in a relatively equal country
everybody's got some money everybody's got some wealth
everybody is a worker everybody is a producer
and everybody is also a consumer
and that means wherever you have a village or a city or
or a town you have workers and consumers
because everybody is a worker
and everybody is a consumer
but once you move towards very unequal economies
then you get like a splitting of workers and consumers
all of the wealth
all of the the economic power
all of the spending power starts to be concentrated in
a small elite and and they are the
people who can spend and everybody else has nothing
and that creates an imbalance right
because if everybody's a worker
and everybody's a spender then any
town any city is
balanced it has both workers and spenders
once you split those people
then suddenly you don't own your own home
you're kind of poor there's only a small amount of
people have money you need to live near them
because that's the only place to get a job
and that's how you see a kind of shape of country
and a shape of city which is really
really common in poor countries in
you know anywhere really Latin America
most of Africa, Southeast Asia
where you have these cities
which have unbelievably luxurious centers
surrounded by massive massive slums basically
that is the shape that an unequal economy wants to be
right because if the rich have all the spending power
then of course they want a super
like luxury place to live
so that they will build that
and everybody else needs to sort of swarm around them
that is what our economy wants to look like
because here in Europe we
have moved from that relatively equal 60s
70s 80s period towards a very unequal
a very unequal economy now
and it is becoming more unequal
so you're starting to see this economic drive
to build these very unequal countries
to very these very unequal cities
and that is why people are saying build more
build more build more
I think we should be very careful
you know I live well
I grew up in one of these areas outside the big city
these places are being very
very aggressively very rapidly slumified
there's lots of
enormously low quality housing being built up
I think you should be careful supporting
these build build
build policies that are not addressing the
growing inequality because if you do that
you will make places like London and places like
all of the big cities across Europe
you will make them start to look more like Mumbai
and like Rio de Janeiro and Sao Paolo
with massive slums. I would like to protect more
the ability of people to live where they want
I don't think people should be forced
to all live in the city
and all live in the massive cities
and to do that
you need to address the growing inequality
not just build more more
more but beyond that
I think there is a really phenomenal
and quite interesting like naivety to this build build
build approach which really mirrors the phenomenal
naivety that we're seeing in a lot of mainstream
economic discourse at the moment
about the weakness of the economy overall
so you know
we have this New Labour government in
in this country and
their approach is
growth growth growth you know
they've got these posters out there to say growth
growth growth and and it mirrors this
this commonly popular idea about the housing market
which is build build build
and it kind of it seems
is based on this Assumption that you can just go and
you can just build a house
or you can just go and you can grow the economy
as if there's a bunch of resources lying around
as if there's like
a million builders sitting on the side
twiddling their thumbs with a bunch of concrete
and you can just bring them in
and get them to start building.
We do not live in
economies full of unused resources
we live in very efficient economies
where basically all resources are used
and the vast majority of those resources
are owned by the rich
are used by the rich and if you are a rich person
you control the resources we need to build more houses
and you get to choose
what you’re gonna do with those resources.
Are you gonna build affordable housing
for ordinary people
you're in this economy
where you can rapidly see the shifting
power dynamics in the economy
the government is dying on its arse right
and that's not just the UK
governments are dying on their arse all over the world
right government is collapsing
the working class is just devastated
the middle class is increasingly impoverished
and you have this small group of super wealthy people
who are just aggressively getting richer and richer
and richer and richer and richer
and you are a rich guy with some resources
that you get to choose what to do with
and you know, you're running a company
if you were running a company now, building company
construction company
in this economic context of a collapsing middle
collapsing government collapsing poor
absolutely skyrocketing wealth of the rich
what kind of housing are you gonna build?
You are gonna build super
luxury housing for super rich people
because they are obviously the guys with the money
right, it'sobviously...
and then when it comes to ordinary people's housing
you're gonna give them the cheapest possible thing
because you know that they have very
very little money
and they basically have to buy whatever they can
whatever they can give you
we we need to deal with this absurdly
simplistic view of economics
which says things like build build
grow grow as if that is not what every government
for the last 30 35 years
all over the world has been constantly trying to do
and failing
the problem here is not not enough building
the problem here is not not enough growth
the problem here is rapid and aggressive
changing in distribution
and changing in your relative power position
if you are not a super rich person
you are the group that is losing
and that means you get less housing
it's as simple as that, build
build build, it's not gonna work
I often think when I hear politicians say build
build build when I go back to the house I grew up in
there's a massive massive
massive block of flats
now. I grew up in sort of a traditional terraced
small row terraced houses
there's a massive block of flats there
now blocking out the sun and the
you know,
that the street I grew up in is basically a slum
now. I always wonder when they say build
build build, these politicians
are they gonna build massive blocks of flats
overlooking their houses?
Or are they gonna build massive blocks of flats
of extremely low quality housing
overlooking your house?
and that brings me to my final point I wanna make
which is
the idea that we just need to to slash red tape
we just need to let them build
so for those who are not watching in the UK
everyone in the UK will know
we had the massive disaster in this
in this country in this city eight years ago
which was when  a block of flats burnt down
it's known as the Grenfell disaster and 72 people died
and it turned out that not just that block of flats
but flats all over the country
including the building that I'm talking to you from
had basically unsafe
materials used in the building construction
and that buildings all over the country
we're not safe from fire. Listen
I'm not a red tape guy
do you really think that
the best way to improve housing affordability
it is to slash
safety standards
I think it's probably not the right way to do it.
So that brings us to an end of this first video
on housing.
I can't believe I've not done one for so long. Listen
build build build grow
grow grow always begs the question, with whose money?
Because the rich own those resources
that you need to build.
Why on earth would they give those resources to you?
They have a choice over what to build
they have a choice over how to use their resources
and you have a choice as well you know
you can try to borrow from them at rates of interest
which have to compete with financial markets that
that wanna build shit for the rich
you'll lose money
you'll run a loss governments will be bankrupted
if you're losing your resources every single day
every single year
you will get poorer and that means less housing
it also means less healthcare it means less education
if you wanna stop that
the only way to realistically do it
is to deal with the fact that you
are losing resources
you cannot live in a country and economy
which is not growing
where the rich get richer and richer
and richer and richer
and not expect to get poorer and poorer
and poorer and poorer
the reason you're losing your housing
is the same reason you're losing your healthcare
it's the same reason you're losing your education
it's the same reason that you're unable to get good
jobs
it's because you are being squeezed out by that rapid
unbelievably rapid growth in wealth and luxury
and living standards of the rich.
If you don't fight that fight
you lose your wealth you lose your resources
you lose your living standards
you lose your housing
so in answer to our opening question
why is housing expensive,
it's because the rich are buying it all
and you can't compete with them
the way to deal with that is to tax the rich more
to tax working people less
that is why we campaign here
to tax wealth not work
support us send this video to your friends
send it to your mum.
It doesn't have to get worse
it can get better
but you're gonna have to make it happen yourself, good luck.